plus de 1000 francs une émission dans
république réalisé par pierre duflot est
animé par lucien jeunesse
chers amis bonjour si l'on en croit la
légende c'est le public un sachet mari
de sainte véronique qui évangélisa le
quercy sous le nom d'amadou qui veut
dire amoureux n'est ce pas il
construisit un oratoire sur le rocher
qui porte aujourd'hui son nom
henri plantagenêt saint louis philippe
le bel louis aux hivers en pèlerinage et
les pénitents gravir longtemps à genoux
les 216 marches menant à la cité
religieuse 309 verts s'y superpose la
vierge noire veille sur la ville et une
cloche qui date peut-être du 4e siècle
sound elle-même pour annoncer les
miracles
monsieur le sobre rocamadour attire-t-il
toujours les pèlerins toujours très
grande quantité de plus en plus de plus
en plus c'est de cet appel rinne âge qui
est suivi depuis avant le moyen âge et
je pourrais vous dire quelque chose qui
vous intéressera savoir que les
personnes du village que j'habite
actuellement venaient à pied faisait 32
km un pied pour assise pour remonter les
216 matches à jouer et on s'en retourner
ensuite le soir avez vous déjà fait ce
pèlerinage monsieur non non mais vous
habitez la région depuis peu oui depuis
deux ans depuis deux ans seulement vous
êtes retraité votre état de l'industrie
oui monsieur gineste vous habitez gramat
qui est à 10 km et vous vous occupez du
syndicat d'initiative
oui oui mais alors je pense que vous
occupez également de rocamadour comme un
lourd et tous les environs mais dark
vador en particulier si ce n'est pas
vous aviez un métier avant d'être bouché
couché le nom de thierry et vous ne
pratiquez plus que vous avez quel âge 75
75 ans mais cette bonne santé vous la
devez je m'adresser à monsieur le sobre
et je vais lui demander de répondre à la
question de mademoiselle laurence
baignoire qui habite sainte maure de
touraine en indre et loire
voici deux dates qui en quelque sorte se
complète 15 ou 1769 et 5 mai 1821 à quoi
se rapporte au tél 15 1769 5 mai 1821
ces dates se rapporte à quelqu'un sur la
date de naissance et de mort de napoléon
eh bien vous avez fait un succès
extraordinaire qu'un vous avez répondu
tout seul aussi question mais monsieur
le boucher s'en réjouit vous pouvez en
rester là vous avez gagné 220 francs ben
je pense que voudraient tenter le
peuvent encore merci pour lesquels
attention mille franc jeu banco de
mademoiselle eliane munster 22 rue de la
respecte
lingolsheim bas-rhin reine de france à
14 ans par son mariage avec charles ciss
elles devaient être plusieurs fois
régente au cours de sa vie elles firent
connaître le roi d'angleterre son gendre
comme héritier légitime du trône de
france
de qui s'agit-il reine de france à 14
ans par son mariage avec charles ciss
plusieurs fois régente elles firent
connaître le roi d'angleterre son genre
comme héritier légitime du trône de
france par un traité de 14 120 le traité
de troyes
oh il aborde aviaire isabeau de bavière
aujourd'hui les comme le super banco
mais c'est quand vous décidez donc vous
ne voulez pas monsieur le boucher hall
non non non mais pas trop fatigué
monsieur le boucher
c'est un très bon capitaine qui grâce à
isabeau de bavière où isabelle de
bavière a gagné taurillon allemand est
très facilement il faut le dire avec le
sourire très décontractés les mille
francs du banco que nous lui offrons de
la part de france inter sous les
acclamations de rocamadour ghana et tous
les environs rires si bravo et à demain
si vous le voulez bien